في الدوره الثانيه لمهرجان البحر الاحمر
سينمائي بالسعوديه
تحكيم جائزتها الخاصه للفيلم السعودي بين
الرمال فيلم بين الرمال مقتبس من قصه
حقيقيه تدور احداث حول تاجر التبغسنان
يقطع احد رحلته ويعود مسرعا الى بيته
ليكون بجانب زوجته التي تضع طفلها الاول
ولكن خلال عودته يواجه الكثير من العقبات
منها كمين اللصوص ومواجهه مع ذئب الفيلم
تم تصويره في مكان الحدث الحقيقي في اليوم
شمال المملكه العربيه السعوديه وهو بذلك
اول القصص التي تم تصويرها هناك في المبين
الرمال هو في من السعوديه بحث من جميع
طاقم العمل بدايه من المخرج كاتب
السيناريو محمد العطاوي وانتاج ريم
العطاوي وجنى دهلاوي وتمثيل رائد الشمري
قد هو فهد فاطمه الشريف وعبيد الودعاني
ينضم لنا من رياض الفنان رائد الشمري بطل
فيلم بين الرمالهم بكراءه يسعد صباحك
شكرا على تواجدك معانا حتى في السياره في
نص الزحمه اهلا بك
صباح الخير
جدا بتواجد معكم هذا اليوم انا اسف والله
ودي يعني كان ودي اني اكون معكم في
الاستديو ولكن
فيلم سعودي تم تصويره في نيوم حديثنا على
فكره الفيلم خصوصا انه مقتبس من قصه
واقعيه حقيقيه تفضل
نعم اول شيء الحمد لله هذا التوفيق من
الله سبحانه وتعالى
فين مبين الرمال اول فيلم سعودي يتم
تصويره من يوم اا
طبعا
القصه يعني مستوحات من من القصه واقعيه
اللي هي قصه مخاويه الذيب
فاا الحمد لله قدرنا نصوره يعني بالشكل
المطلوب وباذن الله ينال على اعجابكم
طيب اليوم لما بنحكي رائد عن اول فيلم
سينمائي سعودي يحضى بطعم لوجستي كامل من
قطاع الانتاج الاعلامي في نيوم ما رمزيات
ذلك ما الذي يعني هو يعني ايه لكم شباب
وممثلين سعوديين
الحمد لله طبعا هذا توفيق من الله سبحانه
وتعالى انه يعني اول مشاركه لي انا شخصيا
يتم ترشيح الفيلم يعني المهرجان البحر
الاحمر السينمائي الدولي وفوق ذلك يتم
يعني الحمد لله يعني خلينا جايزه
افضل فيلم من لجنه التحكيم هذا شيء يعني
يسعدني والله شيء يشجع الشباب او الشباب
الشخص اللي عنده موهبه
يعيد على قولتهم يعني تحدي عنده ويخليه
يعني
يشوفنا مع السعوديه بشكل يعني اكبر طيب
فين بين الرمال تم تصويره في اليوم الى اي
مدى الطبيعه الخلابه وطبيعهم تحديدا ساعدت
في تصوير افلام وفي تصوير حكايه الفيلم
واحداث وتناغم ذلك
فعلا يعني كانت المناظر اول حاجه يعني اول
شيء نيوم هي مدينه المستقبل
فيها اشياء يعني
ممتعه جدا انك انت قاعد تصور تحس انك بنفس
الحكم الزمنيه اللي بوقت القصه يعني
الحقيقيه فتعيش انك تحس انك عايش صح يعني
نفس المكان طيب رائد طالما انت قلت انه
هذه اول مشاركه لك سينمائيه ما الذي اضافه
رائد الشمري ما لم يمكن ان يضيفه اي ممثل
اخر او اي شخص اخر غيرك في هذا الفيلم
طبعا الفيلم ممكن اشيل يساعدني اني اصوره
بشكل تام وبشكل اجمل انه كانت ال ال القصه
يعني
حدثت بشمال المملكه اللي هو بحائل
وكان اللهجه يعني قريبه مني فانا حسيت انه
ما انا قاعد امثل ما انا قاعد اعيش نفس
الشخصيه يعني ماشي هذا هو اللي ساعدني طيب
كيف كان شعوركم بعد ان حازم الفيلم على
جائزه البحر الاحمر او جزر التحكيم في
البحر الاحمر واشادات حظي ارشادات الجمهور
والله الحمد لله والشكر يعني هذا التوفيق
من الله سبحانه وترجع واقول يعني الفضل
الاول لمحمد العطاوي المخرج
والمنتجه جانا دهلوي وريم العطاوي
فشيء شعور يعني ما يوصف والله انا كاول
مره امثل يعني بالسينما فوق ذلك خليت
جائزه يعني شعور شعور جميل يعني لا يمكن
اني اعبر فيه اي والله الفرح مو مو على
قولتهم ما يساعد ابدا
احنا بنشكرك بنتمنى لك كل التوفيق من
الرياض الشمري يسعد هالصباح بطل الفيلم
يعطيكم العافيه